the historical purge that we're
witnessing all over the country is part
of a larger agenda to destroy what it
means to be American and it's getting
more audacious by the day and st. Louis
Park Minnesota the geniuses on the City
Council there recently decided to ban
the Pledge of Allegiance from town
meetings their reason to create a more
welcoming environment to a diverse
community no welcoming to everybody but
Americans who actually love the pledge
well residents were rightly outraged by
this insanity and local Patriots turned
out and they stood up to the City
Council and then in San Francisco the
public defecation capital of the world
taxpayers are going to shell out six
hundred thousand dollars to paint over a
George Washington mural that offended a
few snowflakes there so let me just get
this straight
people peeing in the fountains and
stepping on dirty needles that's not
offensive but the first founding father
is perfect so why would anyone heads are
hearing these kinds of stories be
surprised when someone like leftist
soccerstar Megan Rapinoe who knelt
during the national anthem back in 2016
still refuses to respect it today or
when midfielder Allie long drags the
American flag on the ground while
representing the u.s. on the world stage
and while mugging for the cameras then
drops the flag like it's a piece of
trash thankfully another midfielder
fielder Kelly O'Hara picked it up and of
course Rapinoe discovered early on oh
really that you'll win permanent MVP
status when you kick Donald Trump like
when she used foul language nixing any
traditional White House visit to the
champions and this is before they even
won the World Cup the easiest path to
social media stardom today is one way to
take cheap swipes at American symbols
and traditions and you must understand
that the left truly believes
America itself is illegitimate to its
core what am I talking about
well its founding was fraudulent they
believe its founding documents
meaningless all because of slavery and
the people who were involved in it our
progress on racial issues is
conveniently ignored by cynical actors
who are frankly using these past Horrors
for a power grab and they hope
eventually a total reorganization of our
society here and a massive wealth
confiscation the phrase white privilege
well it's now the preferred weapon of
choice and it's used by socialists
know-nothings
to tar their political opponents and to
avoid real debate only yes what now even
old white Democrats are in the
privileged cross airs I think Joe Biden
fumbles all the time because Joe Biden
suffers from old white male entitlement
what he just can't simply say I was
wrong and liberal women aren't immune
either this week speaker Pelosi learned
that the race table can quickly be
turned on her too she's now under fire
by the four horsemen women of the
Apocalypse
freshman congresswoman who claimed
Pelosi is quote singling out newly
elected women of color
well when asked today about the church
this is how Alexandria Kashia Cortes
responded and knowing the medium
knowing the amount of death threats that
we get No
concentration tension I think it's just
it's racial animus is super no
absolutely no that's a neat trick isn't
it
AOC blasts everyone and anyone any time
of the day or night on social media but
when the leader of her own party calls
her out
she cries foul no no Nancy's not a
racist but well but President Trump is
routinely subjected of course to this
kind of attack
well his plan to put citizenship that
question on the census was roundly
derided
as racist by Democrats and today
referring to that issue he shot back now
they're trying to erase the very
existence of a very important word and a
very important thing citizenship we must
have a reliable count of how many
citizens non-citizens and illegal aliens
are in our country bingo
how is this controversial asking about
citizenship citizenship it's like a
question that has nothing to do with
race at all it's about who is American
and who is not and by the way African
Americans have been the most directly
impacted by the mass flow massive flow
of illegal immigrants in the United
States
no wonder polls now show that a majority
of both black and Hispanic voters
support adding the question to the
census erasing our history our sense of
who we are is making it easier to turn
America into just kind of another member
of a globalist super state Europeans
sacrificed their identities years ago on
the altar of globalism when they form
the European Union and look at what it
got them
[Music]
now we may have masked morons event
Aoife to deal with but we don't have
yellow vest shutting down entire cities
or a brexit style mess to deal with
or a recession on the horizon like we
see with Germany there's a price for
surrending your sovereignty in your
identity and we're gonna pay it if we
don't defend our history and our
traditions and that's the angle